[Music]
people can go and take some pictures on
the phone but again this does open at
midnight
tonight here in downtown las vegas
reporting live on fremont street joe
mullen eight news now
it is loud out there all right let's
head over to chief meteorologist ted
florindo who was at stadium swim right
there on the campus of circa hi ted
hey uh guess what up here during the day
it's been beautiful but now that it's
night and we're seeing
the sun's now going down all the lights
are coming on and you could see the how
huge this pool is and how beautiful it
is
of course the big talk of the town when
this was going up was going to be that
huge led screen
that 14 million megapixel led screens
you can see that's a circle on it
143 by 40 foot screen unbelievable
4 000 capacity here so you could squeeze
4 000 people
in here and there'd still be enough
space to hang out in all the six of the
pools and the two spas
15 000 square feet of wet space so this
is fantastic
it's not on the ground it's actually
five stories up behind it you can
actually
see and most likely probably hear the uh
the fremont street experience so the
sunset up here is incredible
great spot for this pool here on the
south side of the circa fantastic